one of the things that
is also worth mentioning that
i should have covered in the article but
i didn't
is i i think the article may give the
impression
that
the current state of things is fine
actually because when you look at the
forest plots confidence intervals
overlap most of the time research on
males
usually generalizes pretty well to
females so
you know
why does this matter in the first place
why should we want more uh female
participants in these studies
and
so i i did do a poor job of making this
clear in the article but i think one of
the primary reasons
is that
there is a difference between
these two things don't seem to be
super different and these two things are
exactly the same like those are two very
different statements two very different
sentiments and at this point
uh i i suspect there are
true sex differences that do exist
that we currently don't have the
statistical power to detect
uh because
essentially we don't have enough
research to to adequately estimate sex
specific effect estimates so you know uh
just
just to to give an example of that
um
you know let's say
there's uh
so a a great example of this is research
on training volume so there are
a ton of studies with exclusively male
subjects that look at the dose response
relationship between training volume and
muscle hypertrophy
and uh
there are
very i think there are only one or two
studies on female cohorts looking at the
same thing
and so when you look at those two bodies
of literature they generally find the
same thing that to a point higher
training volumes tend to result in more
muscle growth
but
uh there's so little there's so little
research on female subjects we're
nowhere close to being able to sketch
what the dose response relationship for
female subjects might look like like we
can
we can start to do a decent job of that
with male subjects because there's
enough research but we just have no
[ __ ] idea what that dose response
curve for female subjects looks like
and so it could be very similar but not
identical like you know
like let's just assume that the ideal
level of training volume on average for
men is say 15 sets a week uh you know it
could be
18 sets a week 20 sets a week for women
like i don't know if that's the case but
it could be but the thing is like you're
not going to have enough statistical
power to estimate that with enough
precision to know that those like that
that three to five set difference is a
true difference rather than just you
know a
a single estimate from a single study
that needs confirmation so you know
there there very well probably are
some differences that that exist
um
that
we simply can't know about because
there's not enough
research on female subjects
to estimate with any reasonable amount
of precision
how much those effect estimates differ
um
so yeah like in general
this stuff seems to like most research
in our field seems to generalize between
the sexes pretty well
um
but it probably doesn't generalize
perfectly
and there's
currently no way to know
what areas of research male and female
lifters are like very very similar
virtually identical and what areas of
research
maybe there is a
trivial to moderate difference like in
in the cohen's d family like
effect size differences in the 0.1 to
0.5 range like we don't have enough
statistical power to know if if
differences of that magnitude which are
are non-zero differences not night and
day differences but differences that are
probably large enough to actually make a
difference in terms of training
recommendations
we we simply don't have the data
to know
if differences of that magnitude exist
and if so
what areas of research those differences
exist in and and we need more research
on female subjects to
be able to estimate that with with
adequate precision to uncover those
differences
so boiling this down to a kind of
summary bullet points here
basically
you did a meta-analysis or a survey of
meta-analyses on this topic you found
that
uh
female participants are currently
under-represented in the research very
underrepresented very underrepresented
and it seems to be trending the wrong
direction getting worse over time
correct
current indicators suggest that there is
not a massive
you know aggregated night and day
difference to suggest that no male
findings will generalize to female
participants however well i wouldn't
even say that i would say
we can be pretty confident that they
generalize quite well most of the time
but we can't be confident that they
generalize perfectly that there's like a
one-to-one relationship and we need more
female research this is important
because it's going to allow us to
determine where some of those small to
moderate size sex differences are that
actually could be acted upon in terms of
programming nutrition etc yeah